[Applaudissements]
arrêté à jacques ortet son journal pour
lire les nouvelles j'espère qu'elles
seront sous sociaux tels voyages grands
reportages d'anna et balsillie sous
coucy des petites caméras
le petit écho de la forêt c'est l'intrus
breux c'est vrai vous la verrez il y à
toutes les informations à chaque
nouvelle édition on n'a jamais de
déception ça vous le découvrirez dans
l'homme qui découle l'offre
[Rires]
voyons voyons au nom d'un petit ebooks
écouter certains des fans ce soir gros
spectacle de cirque hors bojador le
succès parade ces acrobates et clowns
de plus grands cirques du monde des plus
grands maîtres au matin du monde les
plus friables pauvres du monde n'est
plus grand cloud le dimanche 2 août à
12h30 en concevant qu'on pourra prendre
le spectateur rafle y perdrait il le
spectacle comment chapeau
nasser publie un numéro sensationnel a
dès lors la cigogne au trapèze volant
[Musique]
over bleed la grande halle elle risque
collaborent pour votre plaisir
merci
voici la seule l'unique à des lots de la
cigogne
retenir notre souffle pierre rabhi adèle
va commencer son numéro badi amel bent
mais pourquoi je ne peux pas exécuter
mon numéro haut et pourquoi gradel en
répétant je me suis cassé un ongle
et alors je ne peux pas exécuter mon
quadruples sauts périlleux c'est parce
et ongles là que je me rattrape l1
frei est pas d une chaire publique
l'important c'est de la grande delle
soit en bonne santé
au numéro vivant
à doha présente un merveilleux numéros
de magie
louis un numéro de prestidigitation
trept très rusé puis emma france rpf
voici ce que vous attendez appartements
les grands comptes jeudi
bibeau
picot
ouais
oh
toujours lui qui comme moi qui ai eu le
poil cher public c'est là qu'il faut
rire j'ai compris comment vas-tu ion de
poils tuyau de poêle
c'est très drôle c'est pas fini on va
encore rire comment vaincu you de poils
une fois le butin
or qu'a fait drôle à lhassa et toi la
map la fia mourir de rire
beke pitot avez vous vu monte carlo nous
fumons ces personnes astucieux nous
alors là et j'ai pas compris moi pour
cent c'est rigolo le qubo du refus
montauroux et alors et puis tu me
réponds non j'ai vu mon quelle personne
est alors alors chez legal c'est
vraiment mais on x est rigolo ce projet
au public
oui
alors si c'est rigolo rayon voix j'ai
toujours pas compris on veut continuer
l'autre du bureau mais bien faire mais
je sais plus où rien n'est fait at il
voté d'instants normal on monte carlo où
une souche au monde et d'instants monte
carlo avait été abattu hier après j'ai
compris et
suivez mon regard look elle a su qu'elle
finira bientôt chanter des papilles pour
une preuve d'astuce et 3g dattes et du
thé bullion va plus pour les pieds c'est
qu'on a coupé je n'y arrivais pas
beaucoup
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]